Let's look at the solution to our RAID
0 quiz where we have an array of four
disks, and for one disk we know
the capacity, throughput, and MTTF.
In RAID 0, we're striping the data
across all the disks with no redundancy.
So we can use a capacity of all four
disks, and thus get 800 GB in capacity.
If we spread the read and write load
evenly across the disks, then one disk
being able to support 10 megabytes per
second and four disks being used in
parallel like this gives us a throughput
of 40 megabytes per second.
And finally, if the MTTF for
one disk is 100,000 hours,
the expected MTTF for the whole array
is going to be a quarter of this,
if they are in RAID 0, so
we will get 25,000 hours.
This MTTF ends up being almost 12 years.
This one is almost three years.
If we plan to replace our array after
something like five or six years,
know that it can still fail
within the five or six years, but
on average it's going
to last about 12 years.
However, here our average array is going
to fail during the five to six years.
So obviously with such a low MTTF,
we should not have used four
disks in RAID 0 like this.